después del fuego el agua este viernes
al menos 27 personas perdieron la vida
por las inundaciones que sacuden al país
desde hace dos días tres provincias de
la costa norte están en alerta máxima y
unas 100 personas permanecen
desaparecidas según medios locales el
presidente recep tayip erdogán se
dirigió a las víctimas de la tragedia
no podemos devolver a los que han
perdido la vida pero nuestro gobierno
tiene la fuerza los medios y la
determinación para compensar todas las
demás pérdidas
viviendas carreteras puentes nada parece
impedir el avance el torrente de agua
que destruye todo por su paso
este es nuestro edificio de los troncos
los escombros de los árboles llegaron
por la izquierda y la derecha al mismo
tiempo conseguimos salir colocando
maderas y tablones en las escaleras del
primer piso
algunos perdieron sus casas cuando otros
perdieron sus pertenencias
tengo una casa aquí y una vaca que murió
generamos muchos temen por su futuro
después de la catástrofe así que estoy
acabado tengo dos hijos no me quedan
más de 1700 personas ya fueron evacuadas
y alojadas en residencias estudiantiles
en la zona con 30 localidades sin
electricidad los esfuerzos de los
rescatistas se complicaron la autoridad
meteorológica anunció que se esperaban
más lluvias con la misma intensidad en
la región central y oriental del mar
negro advirtiendo sobre el riesgo de
nuevas inundaciones